I'm in Weldon Spring innocent Louis
Missouri USA and the 1950s and 60s this
strange gray wind blast at Hill wasn't
here instead there was a uranium
processing Factory and conditions for
the workers back then were shocking by
today's standards it wasn't quite the
1940s you can find testimony from back
then of workers hand scooping uranium
ore but there are tales of spilled
radioactive powder of overflowing
disposal pits and of strange-looking
frogs and I am not making that up when
the factory here was running it was
known as the clean one and well it
wasn't the plant here closed in 1966 as
the most contaminated site in the area
PCBs mercury asbestos and radioactive
waste and the 1980s the Environmental
Protection Agency declared Wheldon
spring a Superfund site meaning it would
finally be cleaned up and the result is
this a seven story high nuclear waste
dump the permanent disposal cell
containing more than million cubic
meters of toxic waste and hopefully
keeping local residents safe for the
next thousand years or so and that was
gonna be pretty much all the video if
you searched this place online that's as
far as a lot of articles go except then
I did a bit more research and I found
out about Coldwater Creek a few miles
away where radioactive waste from the
Manhattan Project the project that built
the first nuclear bombs the waste was
just dumped there in the 1940s with the
government's approval that waste
eventually flowed decades later into
people's backyards after flooding that
was in 2015 then there's the West Lake
landfill on the other side of San Luis
where an underground trash fire has been
burning very close to another
radioactive waste site for seven years
now the risk is apparently minor no one
is about find a glowing barrel in their
backyard but radiation hazards are
invisible and terrifying local residents
are concerned about clusters of cancer
diagnoses about infant mortality caused
by contaminated groundwater there are
wells for drinking water only a mile
away the State Department of Health
investigated and the results set no
one's mind at ease there are so many
confounding factors that the facts are
well somewhere between confusing and
unknown and people are scared this site
is a legacy of a time when the people in
charge didn't know or didn't care about
the risks of radioactive contamination
but this isn't a monument how we fix
their mistakes it's a reminder that
we're still fixing them and that we'll
still need to for centuries or millennia
to come